CHARLIE ENGELKE: Hello,
I'm Charlie Engelke,
and I work in Developer
Relations for Google Cloud
platform.
My focus is on serverless
computing, and today's talk,
we're going to see
how you can run
almost anything serverlessly
using Google Cloud platform.
This is important
to me because I
was a software developer for
many years outside of Google.
And I always wanted
to make the path
from it running on my machine
to it's live on the web
as short and simple as possible.
And that's what
serverless computing does.
It lets the developer's path be
as short as possible from when
your application is
working, as far as you
as a developer are
concerned, until it's
working as far as your
customers are concerned.
Serverless computing
has a lifecycle
that, to really break it down
to its simplest possible terms,
is, the developer builds
the app, tests the app,
makes sure it's all working
in the local environment,
and then the platform takes
over and does everything else.
It provisions computing
and storage resources.
It handles logging, monitoring,
health checks, patching,
hardware problems, all that
stuff is the responsibility
platform.
And as a developer,
in the past, that's
what I really wanted to do.
I wanted to focus
on my application,
not on the platform.
So serverless
computing is great.
But it does have a deal you've
got to make as a developer.
If you want to use a
serverless computing platform,
the platform offers
you this bargain.
I'll provide you
specific runtimes--
that is to say,
environments for your app--
and if you want
to use me, you're
going to have to fit into
one of those runtimes.
That's not terribly restrictive.
Google Cloud platform has
several serverless platforms
with a lot of runtimes.
For instance,
there's App Engine,
which has been around
for about a dozen years.
And it supports half a
dozen different languages--
Python, Java, Node, PHP, Go.
And Ruby is currently in beta.
If instead of a web
application, you're
looking to deploy a web
service, Cloud Functions
is a platform for that.
And it has for runtimes
it offers at the moment--
Python, Node, Go.
And Java is currently in beta.
So if you've got an
application in any
of those very common popular
environments, you're set.
You can use one of these
platforms as it is today.
But what if you don't
have your application
fit into one of those runtimes?
For example, what
if your application
needs to run a binary?
It's not just one
piece of source code.
It's several
different components
that run as binary code.
Maybe they're in
other languages.
Maybe you've lost
the source code
or you've licensed
third-party code.
Or they may incorporate
shell scripts.
There's a whole lot
of things that might
make you not fit into here.
For example, you may
have started working
in a brand new language.
And it's a perfect fit for what
you need in your application.
But you can't find a
platform that supports it.
Well, in today's
talk, we're going
to talk about how to
solve that problem.
But we're going to give
it a problem that's
the exact opposite.
Instead of too new
a language, what
happens if you need to run a
45-year-old Pascal program?
To remind all of you may
not remember or may not
have been around, Pascal was the
most popular computing language
for teaching in
the '70s and '80s.
And it was pretty well-defined
in this little slim book,
the "Pascal User
Manual and Report,"
written by Jensen and Wirth.
It was published in 1974, which
is a full third of a century
before any of our modern
serverless platforms existed.
So it's not terribly
surprising that the examples
weren't optimized to work
on serverless computing.
But it does have a
program in it that we just
have to make available online.
I found this program,
and I want everybody
to be able to get the
benefit out of it.
This is it-- the Pascal
program to convert numbers
to Roman numerals.
It may seem fairly
simple, but this
has been around for 45 years.
Any bugs in it presumably
have been well knocked out.
You enter a number, and it gives
you back the Roman numeral.
Now, in order to do this,
first thing I had to do
was look and see what serverless
platforms will run my Pascal
software as is?
And I could not find any.
But I still want one,
because I don't want
to manage my own environment.
I don't want to
run my own servers.
package my software
and deliver it as
code that people run
on their own infrastructure.
I want to take my
application that
is working fine on
my local machine
make it available to anybody
that's got a web connection.
Cloud Run lets me do that.
Cloud Run is Google's
serverless platform
that offers a slightly
different bargain
than the traditional one.
The traditional bargain is,
I'll give you a language
environment, you fit
into that environment
and you can run serverlessly.
Cloud Run's bargain is, instead
of just bring your source code,
you have to bring a container.
Now, when you first hear
that, you might think,
that is a lot of extra
complexity instead of just
bringing my own source code.
You've probably worked some
with Docker or seen about it
or used Kubernetes.
And you know that containers
are extremely flexible,
but there's a lot of
things you can do with it
and a lot of things you
need to learn how to manage.
Cloud Run is actually a
very simple host environment
for a container.
And it can be very easy using
tools on Google Cloud platform
in order to get this
out and running.
And that's what
we're going to see,
the easiest way to take
our Pascal program,
package it in a container, and
let Cloud Run manage it for us.
Containers can be a lot
easier than you might
think, easier than I thought.
The first thing
is, you don't need
to install any of the
traditional container tools.
You don't need to
install Docker,
because Cloud Build,
a Google service,
can actually take your
specification and your source
code and build the
container that you
need for you on Google's own
infrastructure, not yours.
Not only that, you
don't have to figure out
how to build and specify
this container from scratch.
There are a lot of
quickstart examples
that are close to what you need.
And that's what
we're going to do.
We're going to take one of
those and squeeze in our Pascal
program with minor
changes, changes
that don't require
container expertise
and don't require container
software on your own machine.
We're going to start with the
Cloud Run Python Quickstart.
That's at cloud.google.com
/run/docs/quicks
tarts/build-and-deploy.
If you go to that page,
you'll see that there are only
two files in this example.
One is a very simple
Python web application
using the Flask framework that
just says, "hello, world."
Somebody asks for the home
page, it says, "hello, world."
That's it.
The other part of
the quickstart is
a Dockerfile that is the
specification for how
to create the container,
which is to say,
the runtime that that
Python app requires.
We don't have to change a lot to
make this work with our Pascal
code.
We're going to add
the Pascal source
code to the overall example.
So instead of two files,
we're going to have three.
We are going to make the Docker
file compile it into a binary,
because we can't launch the
Pascal program in source code.
We've got to convert
it to an executable.
And then we're going to
tweak the Python program.
So we're going to keep
the Python program.
But instead of it just
saying, "hello, world."
that program is going to
invoke our Pascal executable.
Let's see how that
all is going to work
and why it's going
to work that way.
The starting point, remember,
is that Pascal program,
written in 1974.
Now, Cloud Run's bargain
is, give me a container,
but the container is supposed
to handle web requests.
Cloud Run will take
incoming web requests,
send them to your container,
wait for the response,
and send it back.
That's really all it
expects your container to do
is handle web requests.
This code doesn't do that.
That's because this
code was old enough
to drive before the
web was invented.
This code was written in 1974.
Tim Berners Lee told the world
about the web around 1990.
So not surprising
that 1974 software
doesn't handle web requests.
Instead, it handles requests
from standard input,
and it sends the answers
out to standard output.
We're going to keep
it that way, and we're
going to let the rest of
our runtime environment
handle that for us.
First of all, let's take
a look at the Dockerfile.
The Dockerfile in the
example is simple.
It's only six lines log.
And to deal with
our Pascal example,
we only need to add
three more lines to it.
So the Dockerfile is not
terribly intimidating.
Let's take a look at what
every one of these lines does
and why we need it.
The first line says what
runtime we start with.
We're given a container that
can do a lot of what we need,
and we just need to add to it.
In this case, the container
is a Python container
that can run Python programs.
The last line of this
says, when Cloud Run
invokes this, what software
inside the container
does it execute?
Well, what it's
going to do is, it's
going to execute the Gunicorn
web server using our Pascal
Flask program.
Now, in the middle, we have to
specify the working directory,
where all the software
is expected to be.
We set that up to be /app.
That is /app in the
container's file system,
not on our own local machine.
And we copy all the software in
our current working directory
when we build the container into
the container at that location.
So that's how our Pascal
program gets into the container.
That's also how the Python
program gets in there.
But again, the problem is,
the Pascal program's source
is in the container.
We need the executable.
So the next three lines
install software to do that.
We're using the standard
Debian package installer.
And the first line is to update
it so that, when we install,
we get the latest versions.
Then we install FPC, which
is the Free Pascal Compiler.
That's available,
and it will actually
do the job we need in
the next line, which
is to compile our roman.pas
source code into an executable.
By default, the output
of that compilation step
with the Free Pascal Compiler
will be a file called Roman.
Our working directory is /app.
So we're now going to end
up inside the container with
/app/roman as a
binary executable.
All these run steps,
by the way, are
happening while the
container is being built.
Once we have a container,
they'll all be finished
and they'll be ready to go.
And then the final run
step we have in here
is installing the necessary
Python prerequisites.
We're running an application
that uses the Flask framework,
so we have to install Flask.
And it's running under
the Gunicorn web server,
so we have to use a Python
package installer to install
that as well.
When the container is
built, all the stuff
will be executed
and run and we'll
be ready to go ahead and have
the web server run our code.
Well, our code,
as we say here, is
going to be the Python app
launched under the Gunicorn web
server.
So let's take a look
at that Python app.
The starting point in the
quickstart is a simple, "hello,
world."
And the Flask
framework basically
says, here is a path that
might come in for a request,
and here's the code you
run to respond to it.
So we have here,
@app.route, slash.
The home page path--
just plain slash--
will run the "hello,
world" method.
And all that method
does is, it checks
to see if there's an environment
variable that will say hello
to that instead
of "hello, world."
By default, it then falls
back to using "hello, world."
And then it returns that string.
Hello, world.
That's it, very
straightforward, very simple.
What we need to
do is modify this
so that it actually takes
a number and figures
out the Roman numerals
for the number
and sends the result back.
So first of all,
how are we going
to get the number in there?
Well, the easiest way I know of
is for somebody using their web
browser to put it in the URL.
So instead of requesting
the web page at slash,
request the page as
slash some number.
In Flask, you can specify
that as a placeholder,
and then say, when you run the
"hello, world" method, pass it
that number, which
will be bytes.
We convert that to a string.
And now we have
something that we're
ready to ask the Pascal
program to parse and manage.
So the next step is to run the
Pascal program using the Linux
subprocess module.
We tell it to run our
executable, which, again,
is at /app/roman.
We tell it, for standard
input, send it that string
that we got, the
number to be converted,
and to capture the
standard output, which
will be our Roman numerals.
And then the final
step is, instead
of returning "hello,
world," we're
going to return the
standard output from when
we ran the Pascal program.
That's it, not a lot
of complicated changes.
Let's go ahead and
take a look at how
to do this with Cloud Run.
We're going to have to start
by building the container,
so let's go over to a demo
where we get it started.
Because that can
take a few minutes,
because installing that
Free Pascal Compiler
has a lot of prerequisites.
After we run this
command, we're going
to come back here, talk
about how the command worked,
and what we need to do next
to actually get it to run.
We've created all the
pieces of our application,
and now we want to have it
running on the Cloud Run
platform.
In order to do this, we've
got to create a container,
and we've got to then send
the container to the Cloud Run
service.
That can all be done
from the command
line on your local machine.
But I'm going to actually
do it without anything
installed locally.
And in order to do this, I'm
going to the Google Cloud
Console at
console.cloud.google.com.
This site is where you can
create a new Google Cloud
platform project.
And everything you
do is going to be
in the context of a project,
so we have to create one.
And your project is going
to be a name you give it--
in my case, Engelke Next.
And it'll create a
system-wide project
ID, which, in many cases,
can be the exact same thing,
if the name you picked
is globally unique.
I'm going to build it still
with the command-line tools.
And in order to do that,
instead of running them
on my local machine, I'm
going to activate Cloud Shell.
Cloud Shell comes with
the Cloud Console.
Any web browser can let you
connect to it, any modern web
browser, whether you're
on Windows, Mac, Linux,
a chromebook, you name it.
Once you connect
to it, it's going
to give you a pre-provisioned
Linux instance,
and you can run
the commands there.
Let's take a look at what's
already in my instance.
I've been here before,
so I've already
got a directory with the source
code we've seen so far in it.
There are a couple of ways
you can get that source
code onto your Linux
instance for Cloud Shell.
One is, you've got tools
like Git already installed,
so you can get something
from a Git Repo.
Or you can use the commands over
here in a menu to upload files
from your local machine.
There are a variety
of ways to do it.
In this case, they're
already there.
So let's take a look at the
files that we've created.
And go ahead and
build the container.
We want to build it in the
Google Cloud platform using
the Google Cloud Build service.
The command for that is gcloud
builds, with an S, Submit.
And then we give it a tag
so we can find it later
in order to deploy it.
That tag is going to be in an
artifact repository in gcr.io.
In this case, I've
named it based
on my project, Engelke Next.
And I've given it
a service name.
It could be pretty
much anything.
Since this is for
Roman numerals,
I picked a service called Roman.
If this is a first time you've
used the Cloud Build service,
you may be prompted that
it's got to be activated.
And it'll offer to
do that for you.
It'll add a couple of
minutes to do the build.
Normally, building a container
can be relatively quick.
But in this case, it's
going to take quite a while.
And that's because we have
this container installing
software, including the
Free Pascal Compiler.
That turns out to have an
awful lot of dependencies
and it's going to take a
while to do that full build.
So we're going to go
ahead, go back to our talk
and see what the
commands actually
mean that we've just done.
And we're going to see what
other commands we need to do.
We'll come back here after
this build is finished.
All right, what we just did was
use the Cloud Shell in the web
console for Google
Cloud Platform
to actually invoke a command
that's going to run Cloud Build
and build our container.
Let's take a look at all
the pieces of the command
and what we asked it to do.
The first part is the
gcloud command-line tool.
We could run this locally
on our own machine.
But if we did, we'd
have to install it.
We'd also have to
set up credentials
on our local machine
saying that we
are authorized to actually build
a container using Cloud Build.
If we do this all
under the Cloud Shell,
everything is set up
for us ahead of time.
So we can run the
gcloud command,
but we want to run Cloud Build.
The subcommand for
that is builds--
build, S.
And what it's going
to do is create
a container using
the specification
in the environment.
We can specify it in a
lot of different ways.
By default, it's going
to look for a Dockerfile
in the current
directory and use that.
After it's done, we want it to
submit that container somewhere
so it's ready for us to
pass on to Cloud Run.
We're going to submit it
to an artifact repository
and tag it with a name that is
based on our current project
ID.
As you saw, the project
we were working on
was called Engelke Next--
I used my name to make
it [INAUDIBLE] unique--
and then slash, the
name of a service.
And we can use just about
anything for that service name.
We used Roman because
this service is going
to give you Roman numerals.
Once that's finished-- and
we'll go back in a minute
and see that it's finished
and go on to the next step.
Once it's finished,
we're ready to then ask
Cloud Run to go ahead
and take that container
and deploy it serverlessly.
And we use the same gcloud
command-line interface
to do it.
But in this case, since we're
talking to the Cloud Run
service, the subcommand is run.
So it's going to
be a gcloud run.
And then the action we want
it to perform to deploy it.
We need to tell it
what image to deploy.
And it's in that same
artifact repository.
We tell it how it was tagged.
And then we've got to tell
it where to deploy it.
Because Cloud Run is available
on Google Cloud platform fully
managed, but it's also
available on an environment
you manage, either on Google
Cloud or somewhere else,
like your own infrastructure.
We've got to tell it
which of those to deploy.
And as you saw from my
talking about how much I
like serverless, you know
I like to do the least
and have the platform
do the most, which
means I want to deploy it
to the managed platform.
And then the final thing
we have to put in here
is something about who's
allowed to run this.
Because by default,
Google Cloud Run
will require all web requests
coming in to be authenticated.
It will only actually pass them
to your Cloud Run container
if they're authenticated
by somebody you permit.
Well, this particular
service, the Roman numerals,
is too valuable.
We can't hold it
back from the world.
We want everybody
to be able to do it
without any authentication.
So we include the
allow-unauthenticated flag.
Let's go ahead back to the
demo, run this command.
It doesn't take quite
as long to deploy it
as it took to build it
because of that install step
we had in the build.
And then we'll see
how it actually works.
The container is
finished building.
We can see that it was a
success and it was pushed.
So now we can go ahead and
deploy it with the gcloud run
deploy command.
Again, if it's the first time
you've done a Cloud Run deploy,
you may be asked to
activate some APIs.
And it'll do that for you.
In this case, that's
already been done.
But it's going to ask what
I want to call the service.
And it will infer
from the tag I gave it
that I want to call it Roman.
Roman Numerals,
that's a good name.
And then where to deploy it?
I'll go ahead and deploy it
to the US central 1 region.
Now I'm going to
deploy the container.
And this takes a few minutes,
because it's not only
going to deploy the service.
It's got to set
up access control,
even though we said,
allow unauthenticated.
And it's got to set
up traffic routing
so that everything gets to
this cloud container properly.
Once it's finished
running, we'll
be able to go take a
look at what URL is
and actually invoke it.
So while this is still
going ahead and running,
let's go ahead and, in the
top part of the console,
go take a look at
the Cloud Run part.
And we can see this is being
built. It's not finished yet.
If we take a look
at the details,
we'll see it's
still in progress.
Once it's finished, this
will show us the URL.
Right now it says it's loading.
And after it finishes
showing us the URL,
we'll be able to invoke
the service just by opening
a web page with that URL.
If we didn't tell it
allow-unauthenticated,
we'd have to send an
authenticated request, one
with a header that contains
proof of our identity.
This is going to be a
lot easier in this case.
All right, the revision
deployment is finished.
It's been deployed.
It's serving 100%
of the traffic.
And here's the URL.
When we invoke the
URL, we're going
to be disappointed
right at first.
And that's because it comes
back with an error message.
Well, that error message
is not Cloud Run's fault.
Our Python wrapper
program told how
to handle URLs that had
slash followed by a string
that we were going to
interpret as a number.
This URL does not
have that string,
so we didn't tell
it how to handle it,
so the Python
wrapper function just
doesn't know what to do with
it and returned an error.
Let's go ahead and
tell it, we want
to take a look at the
Roman Numeral for 1974.
And it comes back
and gives us that.
It's not in the shortcut
for Roman Numerals.
When they wrote this
program, it was easier
to write it this
way, and clearer
for the purpose of teaching.
But also the fact is,
in the earliest days,
Romans didn't tend to use
the shortcut versions anyway.
Let's try another number.
You may have noticed when you
were looking at my console
that I am doing this
recording on July 20.
That is the anniversary
of the first lunar
landing on July 20, 1969.
So let's take a look at
1969 in Roman numerals.
And again, it converts
it right away.
Anybody in the world
that knows this URL
can go ahead and
do this conversion,
as long as this is live.
The next slide, once
I show it in the demo,
will actually have
a URL that I'm
going to be leaving
live for a few months
if you want to try
it out yourself.
Or of course, you
can deploy your own.
Now, this is not a very
easy URL to memorize or give
to other people.
You can, if you have
your own domain,
actually configure Cloud Run
to respond with a page at one
of the URLs on your own domain.
We're not going to
cover that here.
It's fully documented
in the web pages.
OK, as you saw it was
pretty easy to actually
create the container without
having any local install
and to deploy it to Cloud Run.
And now it's available on
the internet for everybody
to access.
That URL that I did the demo
is for a throwaway project.
It's not going to keep
running for very long.
But I still have this available
at this URL on the slides
so you can come
back in any time,
and you go to that web
page, because you probably
need to convert numbers to
Roman numerals all the time.
We're going to keep
this application up
for the next several months,
not promising it forever.
Now again, this is not
the world's friendliest
URL to memorize.
It is possible to actually
use your own domain
and have your own URL pointing
to the service as well.
We're not to cover
how to do that,
but it's fully documented
at the website.
We have now seen
that you can run
almost anything serverlessly.
And you do that by
creating a container.
And containers can be easy
with Google Cloud platform,
with Cloud Run and Cloud
Build to create them.
You can do that without
any local Docker install.
And if you use
Google Cloud Shell,
you don't need to have
anything on your own machine
except a web browser, which,
if you're watching this talk,
we know you've got a web
browser available to you.
You can start with a lot
of Dockerfile samples
that are close to what you need.
So you don't have to
learn how to create
Dockerfile specifications
from scratch.
And in fact, depending on what
you need your container to do,
you may not have to have
a Dockerfile at all.
Buildpacks, which are described
at buildpacks.io, that website,
can eliminate the need
for a Dockerfile entirely.
They can actually look at
your source code structure
and create the
container from that.
I don't think you're going
to find a buildpack, however,
that can handle Pascal.
But all said and
done, everything
we did here is something you're
probably not going to do need
to do exactly as given.
You're probably
not going to need
to run Pascal software
on a serverless platform.
But it's a lot more likely
you may need to run something
in a language that's too new
to have much support on source
code-oriented
serverless platforms.
And in fact, it's
extremely likely
that your application is going
to have many components that
include pieces you've already
got in binary-only form,
either because they've
been around your company
for a while, you've
lost the source code,
or possibly, you've licensed
them in binary form only.
Or you may have other old
languages unlike Pascal.
It's a lot likelier you may
need to run old Fortran or COBOL
programs.
All of those are
things you can do now,
because Cloud Run
greatly expands
the universe of software that
you can run serverlessly.
You can run almost anything.
That's what we promised.
But there are a couple
of restrictions.
We mentioned that
your software is only
going to be run in order
to process web requests.
Cloud Run's not going to invoke
your software unless it has
a request for it to respond to.
And after it gets
a response, it's
going to stop your
software from running.
So you can't leave anything
running all the time
in the background.
The other restriction
is, your software
has got to be stateless.
If you put something
in your source code
that, for example,
has a global variable,
keeping a count
of how many times
you've received a
web request, well,
every time a web
request comes in,
it may be going to a
different container
and affecting a different
global variable.
It's not going to
have any meaning.
If you need to keep state, don't
keep state in your container.
Keep state external
to it, for instance,
in an external database.
So I hope this has
been useful, that you
have seen that learning how
to run a 45-year-old Pascal
program on a modern
serverless platform
can show you some other
techniques that actually
are more applicable
to your general use.
If you have any questions,
please use the Q&A. We'll
be answering them as quickly
as we can get to them.
And again, thank you very
much for your attention.